seven two six number again just text the
word call spam
nice one again yeah there you go seven
seven two six text word call
see that number
members we're uh we're live and ready to
uh to start
the hearing thank you sonja
good morning uh welcome to this
licensing
subcommittee on the first of june 2021
uh the application is um the premises
license application for 105 london road
rally
essex my name is uh council phil shaw
i'm chairing this
meeting today and if i could ask my
fellow members
to introduce themselves please
i'll take off from you i'm councillor
thank you um have we any legal advisor
turned in today
not not not today yeah counselor thank
you
could i ask the counselors license
officer to introduce themselves
hello i'm carys brooke and i'm the
licensing officer
did i ask the applicants to introduce
themselves
good morning chair i'm graham hopkins
from gt licensing consultants
uh mr tosman kyrie is at the hospital at
the moment as
you may be aware right thank you have we
any
uh responsible authorities are attending
today
no chairman thank you are there any
other interesting parties
the are the premises license holder
available
uh no chair mr tostakaya the applicant
is at
the hospital um i won't say too much
online for obvious reasons but
he hadn't he's been monitored for a
suspect lump
and he had an appointment i was unaware
of so the application to today is with
respect if you if
you and the members are agreeable to
adjourn the hearing to a date forthwith
thank you that's what i was going to
come along to that thank you if your
words members has anybody any questions
are you
required to ask
no i have no questions no thank you
chairman
as the licensing officer anything they
wish to say
no so members obviously we've heard that
the applicant
cannot attend today through to a
hospital appointment
um can i then ask if
members are willing to uh adjourn the
meeting
to a further date which will have to be
um discussed
i'm happy with that chairman yeah i'm
very happy with that chairman
are the licensed officer of having to
adjourn the meeting
yes can i then ask
that uh we'd adjourn this meeting then
to a further date and
rearrange it and notify everybody when
that date is arranged
i agree chairman thank you chairman
thank you then i will then
um close this at 9 32.
thank you chair thank you thank you